i'm gonna walk over to sam
well that's my intention because he's
over there
so i come forward
forward now how would the hell
how how would the weapons helped hide it
soon
a lot of you may have found this one
difficult
this morning
just watch when i'm going to tell you
about this but
so i'm going forward
forward i'm actually passing that like
this
okay
switch your knees
when i come here
to here this must be above my head or
else
it will damage me when it comes when it
comes down
this is the natural path so when i come
down
that's the natural path there if i have
it
close too close to me
if i do this i now have to start my
energy up again
if i do it like this
i gather my energy so i go here
i gather my energy it makes like a loose
it comes all right so top to bottom
we don't see this move but some people
kind of
it's very individualistic this because
it's how you
feel it flowing but in the end and this
is a good
short castle that you can do
for yourself
this part you're not getting anybody
it's got to be
that what you're doing
is you're doing this
spinning it up right it's not a spin
it's not
it's not spin it's a
so
i call it like a caressing
because we're hoping
to gather and make it beautiful
and then all the things i've been
teaching you that can the time in the
foot
they keep repeating their self hopefully
and that's how you you improve your eye
without thinking
you don't get their neck on the women
you try to